Oh hi! I hope you don't
mind that I'm eating.
This is actually
just my first course.
For my birthday, the
writers wrote me a script
where I just get to eat!
The whole time!
And I can't think of a
better way to demonstrate
the workings of the
digestive system,
the series of hollow organs
that we use to break down
and process the nutrients and
energy we need to function.
Though...wait a second,
if I remember correctly
digestion is actually pretty
freaking disgusting...
so maybe I shouldn't
be eating right now.
Oh whatever... Waiter!
The digestive system is so
fundamental that it's basically
step number one in the
guide: How to Make an Animal.
You probably remember that during
the embryonic development of most
animals, the digestive tract is
the very first thing that forms.
When the blastula, that little wad
of cells that we all used to be,
turns into a little wad of cells
with a tube running through it,
that tube is your digestive system.
And pretty much every animal has
a digestive system of some kind,
but they're not all alike.
Far from it.
In fact, digestive tracts
are specially adapted
to animals' feeding
behavior and diet.
For instance, a house fly eats
mostly liquid or very finely
granulated food, but
before it does that,
it's got to puke its digestive
juices all over its lunch
and then let them
digest it for a while
before it sucks it
up into its mouth.
If we did it like that, first
dates would be...less common.
Most vertebrates put food
in one end of the tube
and our digestive
system processes it,
and then it gets rid of the waste
out the other end of the tube.
No muss, no fuss.
Well, actually, there's a
little bit of muss, at the end.
You may have noticed.
But the beauty of it is that
this whole process is run by our
autonomic nervous system, so we
don't have to think about it,
until maybe the very last
step when we're in traffic
and just had two cups of
coffee and a bran muffin...
then we have to think
about it a little bit.
Among vertebrates, the digestive
tract might be short or long,
or have organs that
do different things
depending on what its
feeding habits are.
For instance, dogs are mostly
carnivores and also scavengers:
They mostly eat meat,
but sometimes that meat's
been dead for a while.
So, the dog's digestive system
has developed to take food in,
absorb as many
nutrients as possible,
and then deposit it
on somebody's lawn,
all in a period of
about six hours.
Dogs have an extremely short
digestive tract, because,
if you're in the habit
of eating rotten meat,
you'd better be able
to digest it fast.
If you don't, the bad bacteria
that's probably living on that
armadillo carcass is going to
take up residence in your gut
and put you in a world of hurt.
Cows, on the other hand, take
a very very very long time
to digest their food,
around 80 hours,
because they have to process
plants, mostly grass.
Grass has a ton of cellulose
in it, and evolution has yet
to produce an animal that can
manufacture a stomach acid
or enzyme tough enough
to break down cellulose.
So, cows have microorganisms
in their guts
that break down the
cellulose for them.
This process takes a
four-chambered stomach
each one with a slightly
different microecology
and a lot of cud-chewing,
or regurgitating and
re-chewing of grass
before it passes all
the way through.
So, nature is full of
crazy digestion stories,
and I honestly wish that I
had time to tell them all.
But let's focus on human digestion
from now on, mostly because:
You're probably a human, we
don't assume anything here,
and you'll be wanting to know
how YOUR body does all this stuff.
And humans actually have
a have a pretty good
all-purpose digestive system:
We're omnivores, after all,
we eat plants AND meat
so our systems are generalized
to handle all kinds of stuff.
Like most animals, humans have
a bunch of different acids
and enzymes in our digestive
tracts that break food down
so that it can be absorbed
and used by our bodies.
But the secret to
successful digestion
is maximizing surface area.
In more that one way, actually.
The first way we maximize surface
area is on the food itself.
Say I take a bite
out of this apple.
Right now there's like, an apple
boulder sitting there in my mouth.
I've got enzymes in my
saliva that immediately start
breaking it down, like,
the outsides of the boulder.
If I swallowed this
chunk whole right now,
not only would it hurt like heck,
the rest of my digestive system
would have a really hard time
dealing with it, because
most of the enzymes and acids
would have the same difficulty
working all the way
through this big solid hunk.
But, when I use my awesome teeth
to chew up this hunk of apple
suddenly there's double, triple,
quadruple the surface
area on the food!
I'm making up apple gravel
from the apple boulder.
Maybe even apple sand.
For humans, chewing is key because
breaking down our food into
smaller and smaller bits allows
enzymes and acids to get at them.
And after our teeth have
made the pieces small enough,
the chemicals break them
down further until
they're fine enough for our bodies
to absorb nutrients from them.
But it's not just the surface area
of the food that's important,
the surface area of
the digestive system
is key to the whole
process as well.
Last time I talked about
how we have a whole bunch
of surface area in our lungs to
absorb tons of oxygen all at once.
Well, our digestive systems
work in much the same way.
Most of the absorption of nutrients
happens in our small intestines,
and the length of the average
human adult's small intestine
is about 7 meters!
Plus, inside our small intestines
there are a bunch of little
folds and little absorbing fibers
with absorbing fibers on them,
and no I didn't mis-speak,
the fibers have fibers..
that's how hard our intestines work
to increase their surface area.
Last episode I was all
impressed that lungs had
a total surface area
of 75 square meters...
well the small intestine has a
surface area of 250 square meters!
Blegh... It's kind of gross.
I wouldn't want to see it spread
out over a tennis court or anything
But I'm getting
ahead of myself here.
Digestion does not start at
the small intestine, people,
it starts at the mouth.
Now, as you can see, this
hot pocket is surrounded
by some kind of bread,
if you can call it that.
Bread is a starch, which
breaks down into glucose.
When I start gnawing
on a piece of bread,
because the outside
here is mostly bread.
the glands in my mouth
start secreting saliva,
which contains salivary amylase,
an enzyme designed to break
down starch into glucose.
The more I chew, the more amylase
will get to all the different
sides of the bread, and that's
why the more you chew bread,
the sweeter it tastes.
Amylase doesn't really do much
to the meat or the cheese
in this thing.
I've got other enzymes and acids
that are going to work on them
later on in the system, but I am
gonna chew all that stuff up
real good right now so
that those other enzymes
can do their jobs later.
I'm gonna swallow all this.
So now the masticated hot pocket
has passed down my pharynx,
or throat, and into my esophagus,
which leads to my stomach.
There's actually this
little cool flap of tissue
called the epiglottis that blocks
the trachea when I swallow,
so that the food doesn't end
up in my respiratory system.
This ball of food
that I just swallowed
actually has a scientific
name, it's called a bolus
and it rides a kind of wave of
muscle action down the esophagus
into the stomach.
This wave-like contraction of the
smooth muscles around the tube
of the esophagus is called
peristalsis, and it's basically
how most of the movement in your
digestive system is accomplished.
Now my hot pocket bolus
is in my stomach now
which is where the food really
starts getting manhandled.
The stomach basically
takes a scorched earth
approach to digestion.
It's not messing around.
It's like a churning cement
mixer that can contract
and expand with these big,
accordion-like folds
of muscle called rugae.
Your stomach's job is to
turn everything over and over,
smooshing and mixing
all the pieces up
with its cocktail of acids and
enzymes called gastric juice.
Gastric juice is mainly made
up of hydrochloric acid,
an enzyme called pepsin,
and some mucus and water.
Hydrochloric acid
has a Ph of about 1
which is strong enough that,
if you got it on your hand,
it would give you a chemical burn.
So the acid breaks things
down and hopefully kills
most of the bacteria that
you might find on your food.
The pepsin starts breaking down
proteins into amino acids.
Now, that mucus is important.
It's there to protect your stomach,
so that it doesn't digest itself.
When you don't have enough of that
mucus you get peptic ulcers,
which happen when
your stomach lining
comes in direct contact
with your stomach acid.
And the water's just in there
to make everything all soupy,
because what you want by the
time your food leaves your stomach
is chyme, which is a kind of
liquidy slop that you might
be familiar with from the last
time you had a stomach virus.
You knew this conversation
was going to have to get
a little bit gross and I didn't
want to bring diarrhea into it
too much because, you
know, I've been eating.
But when something bad is going
on in your digestive tract,
your body doesn't worry too
much about absorbing nutrients,
it just wants to get
the chyme out of there.
So, chyme is what you see when...
You get the picture.
Anyway, there's a
little valve, or sphincter
between the stomach and
the small intestine
that regulates how much chyme
gets into the small intestine
and when it gets in there.
The very beginning of the small
intestine is called the duodenum,
this is where a lot of the
small intestine action happens,
by which I mean, lots of things
get absorbed and also secreted,
like bicarbonate, which
neutralizes the gastric acid
before it goes any further.
Now, the coolness of the small
intestine can't be overstated.
It's ground zero for
cellular exchange of nutrients
and the breakdown of fats.
And again, the reason
it's so good at absorbing
is because of all the surface
area it's got going on.
A lot of that surface area
comes from the fact that,
despite its name, your small
intestine is frickin' long:
in a human, it can range anywhere
from 4.5 to 10.5 meters.
But that's not all!
The whole inside is lined
with epithelial tissue
that has tons of ridges
and folds in it.
Surface area to the max!
And on those ridges and folds are
these little hair-like fibers
of flesh called villi.
Each villus has capillaries in it,
so that it can absorb nutrients.
And get this: each villus, which
is only like half a millimeter long
is covered in teeeny
tiny little microvilli,
providing even more surface area!
In fact, apparently, the
small intestine has a texture
kind of like velvet, which is...
[DISGUST]
Oh great, now I eat the
milkshake? Fantastic. Okay.
So another thing the
small intestine does,
with the help of its
friend the gallbladder,
is break down fatty stuff,
like this milkshake.
Near the top of your small
intestine is a little pipe
where bile salts,
manufactured by the liver
and stored by the
gallbladder, are squirted out
into the small intestine.
Bile works like dish
detergent on a pan
you just fried something in:
it's an emulsifier.
It takes hydrophobic fat
molecules and breaks them up
into fatty acids
and monoglycerides,
which can be absorbed by all
that epithelial tissue!
I've never had Chunky Monkey before
Mmmmm!
Nuts!
After your food passes through
those yards and yards
of small intestine, the chyme
goes through another sphincter
and enters the cecum, the
beginning of the large intestine.
The large intestine's job is
to remove most of the water
and bile salts from the chyme so
you don't have constant diarrhea.
So, you can thank it for that!
It's called "large" because it's
wider than the small intestine,
but it's not nearly as long:
it's basically just a one-
and-a-half meter victory lap
around outside of the small
intestine and then it calls it good
Also, I should mention,
at the end of the cecum
there is a little tube where
the the appendix comes in.
For a long time, we thought that
the appendix was a worthless,
vestigial structure that we
used to need at some point
in our evolution but
didn't need anymore.
However, recent studies are finding
that the purpose of the appendix
in modern humans is probably
to act as a safe house
for all of the good bacteria you
need to help you digest your food.
If you get a virus or
food poisoning or something
and all your digestive systems
say, "GET IT ALL OUT OF ME!"
The appendix has a little
sample of your gut bacteria
that it spits out to help
recolonize you after your illness.
So, I think you're familiar
with the final step
in the digestive system.
That's the pooping.
Your food can spend as long as
3 days in your digestive tract,
and a lot of that time is
spent in the large intestine,
mostly reabsorbing the
excess water from the chyme
and prepping your poo for its
great entrance into the world.
When it's done, it passes through
everybody's favorite sphincters,
the anal sphincters.
There are two of them.
And, you know...out in the
world to live its own life.
And that's the end of
our little tale here
that begins with the hot pocket.
I hope you'll join us next
time for more disgustingness,
as we discuss the details
of the Excretory System!
Until then, bon appetit!
Thank you for watching this
episode of Crash Course Biology.
If you want to go back
and review anything.
Table of contents
just click on it.
Thanks, of course, to everybody who
helped put this episode together.
If you have questions for
us, please leave them
in the comments below,
or on Facebook or Twitter.
And our team of experts
will attempt to answer.
Goodbye.